who do you not think deserves to be in
the charts at the moment things really
powerful hi I'm Katie and these are the
shocking questions hi I'm Tony
and these are my [ __ ] answers have you
ever not made it to the bathroom in time
if so tell us the story
yes I've definitely not made it to the
bathroom anytime was it a number one or
a number two no it's always a number one
thankfully okay I think it was maybe a
time I was about to go on stage or I was
on stage and I have to come off of stage
yeah I mean luckily for a guy you can
just pretty much piss anywhere who is
the person you're most proud to have as
a follower on social media oh that's a
good question but to be honest I'm not
really proud about any one person in
particular they're so sorry I had that
for too long sorry oh wow okay it's
still going strings really powerful is
it okay okay right do you stand up or
sit down when you're wiping your bum
oh I sort of do this kind of 45 degree
thing
can you show yeah it's kind of like her
cuz if you sit down your hand has to go
into the ball right it's a bit mad do
what you do I sit down you sit down what
you don't I find that a very alien
concept is it yeah all right we yeah we
go different ways yes who do you not
think deserves to be in the charts at
the moment oh I think anyone just making
music we all have the same shot the same
time what is your most disgusting habit
whenever I use tissue they have a habit
of lat
up in my pocket but like not leaving oh
yeah and I little pasta and orange peels
as well even orange peel in a tissue no
I put already pills in my pocket
yeah what is the most embarrassing thing
you've ever done on stage there we go
sorry babes oh that's all right it's
fine it's fine which celebrity would you
most want to go on a date with again
what is your sexiest feature yeah so
this is the last question right ready
make it a great answer please yes have
you peed in the shower in the last year
I've peed in the shower but I've
definitely not peed in the shower in the
last year cuz when I peed in the shower
I think I asked I did like her I asked
my counsel and I was like peeing in the
shower you are my personal counsel my
personal my Council of people I was like
peeing in the shower is this is this a
thing or is this not a thing right and
apparently for most people it's not a
thing interesting do you pee in the
shower I will neither confirm nor deny
yeah so yeah I haven't done it for a
while but I've definitely done it so
we've got to the end of the questions
it's quite heavy phone amazing thank you
that was fun
don't tell anyone the stuff I won't I
won't tell anyone
you